leon goretzka und der fc bayern haben
nach der champions league niederlage im
viertelfinal hinspiel villarreal
entweder noch in den köpfen oder das
rückspiel am mittwoch bereits vor augen
anders lässt sich der mühsame auftritt
gegen augsburg nicht erklären an chancen
mangelte es nicht es braucht aber ein
handspiel von reese oxford bis der
knoten platzt robert lewandowski in der
82 minute mit dem entscheidenden treffer
thomas müller bedankt sich er ist der
erste feldspieler überhaupt der die
marke von 300 siegen in der bundesliga
erreicht ein weiterkommen gegen
villarreal dürften noch mehr freunde
der himmel weint in stuttgart und auch
bei dortmund gewann irena kullern die
tränen der us amerikaner verletzt sich
bereits in der zweiten minute wieder ein
rückschlag für das große talent für ihn
kommt julian brandt und der schreibt in
der 12 minute mit dem frühesten jokertor
in der bundesliga geschichte das
schiedsrichtergespann entscheidet
zunächst auf abseits beim pass von bell
in holland ist aber alles korrekt groß
ja dortmund ist am freitagabend besser
und effizienter auch weil brand nach
seiner einwechslung einen kick start von
null auf hundert hinlegt und im regen
besonders trocken abschließt zweiter
durchgang 71 minute reus auf brand
erster doppelpack für den
nationalspieler im bvb dress hier
spielen ohne niederlage erleidet der vfb
einen rückschlag im kampf um den
klassenerhalt
erstmals findet das bundesliga derby
hertha gegen union im ausverkauften
olympiastadion statt die dachbahn aus
köpenick in den roten trikots saugen die
atmosphäre denn die hara budget nach
mehr als einer halben stunde der japaner
zeitgleich an wir müssen rüber zu den
fans eine fantastische kulisse berlin
ist am samstagabend auch die
fußballhauptstadt jede menge büro liegt
in der luft nicht alle behalten dabei
den durchblick timo baumgarte bringt die
abstiegsgefährdeten gastgeber anfang der
zweiten halbzeit durch ein eigentor
zurück den musst du so erstmal machen
union mit der direkten antwort grieger
prömel in der 53 minute fünf seiner
insgesamt acht bundesliga tore erzielte
er per kopf hier sieht bank warum es ist
eine union gala auch fall härter dafür
den roten teppich ausrollt giraldo
becker besser mann auf dem platz der
dritte derby sieg der saison wird bis
zum schluss zittern sven michel 4 zu 1
hertha bleibt am ende nur noch der
schmerzhafte gang zu den enttäuschten
anhängern
der bestimmung und volles haus auch bei
köln gegen mainz die gäste in den
dunklen trikots gehen durch jonathan
burkhardt in der 14 minute in führung
bitter und kurios dass ausgerechnet die
mainz leihgabe luca kilian den schuss
unhaltbar abfälschte
spielerisch sorgen die nullfünfer im
karnevals- faschings- duell für mehr
konfetti carillon niveau nach dem
seitenwechsel mit dem nächsten
stimmungsdämpfer für die hausherren der
österreicher überragend aus spitzem
winkel der dom steht schief köln will
sich die schmach nicht geben modells
thierry verdiente anschlusstreffer zwei
köpfe füreinander
bei mainz ist die luft raus und köln
fängt jetzt erst an der new beetle
schmidt dem ausgleich
und der torsteher partie soll erst noch
kommen 82 10 minute wieder eine ecke
kilian die mainzer gabe dreht das spiel
völlig verrückt oder wie der kölner sagt
da bist du ganz er ist überhaupt nicht
in party-stimmung florian kufeld und
wolfsburg haben die letzten drei
bundesligaspiele verloren im
abstiegsduell gegen bielefeld läuft es
aber richtig gut lukas matcher
traumstart elfte minute die arminia
völlig von der rolle und manager immer
da wo ein stürmer stehen wo es 38 da
nach einer über sein gutes
positionsspiel
der vorfeld zeigt auf einmal was er
normalerweise im report war hätte
maximilian arnold und das feine füße
die gäste schauen nur staunen zu 53
minute max kruse ganz frei 4 0
schlusspunkt des ersehnten
befreiungsschlag
auch große mönchengladbach hatte sich in
dieser saison mehr vorgestellt beim
tabellenletzten greuther fürth geht es
um wichtige punkte für den klassenerhalt
hoffnung macht das offensivduo player
türrahmen führung in der 18 minute die
beiden verstehen sich blind was man von
den gladbachern auf der bank beim
abklatschen nicht wirklich behaupten
kann auch player bekommt sein tor per
foulelfmeter
die fohlen sind erstmals in dieser
spielzeit und damit erstmals unter adi
hütter seit vier bundesligaspielen in
serie ungeschlagen dieser kleine bochum
fan hat das wichtigste schon in der hand
da brauchte er nicht viel mehr zu sehen
einen besseren blick braucht allerdings
schiedsrichter felix und das zeigt sich
nach mehr als einer stunde foulelfmeter
für leverkusen richtig entschieden die
awi trifft darf aber nicht jubeln weil
zweier ganz genau hingeschaut hat und
siehe da die awi rutscht beim schuss weg
und schießt sich dann selbst an doppel
berührung des schützen zählt nicht sieg
ohne chance ist aber so bochum
leverkusen entstanden zu null
unglaublich
da spielst du in der europa league
einmal gegen wasser und dann machst du
mit dem ball solche kunststücke
christian streich und der sc freiburg
könnten in der nächsten saison sogar
champions league spielen lassen sich
davon aber nicht blenden seine
mannschaft kommt in frankfurt trotzdem
groß auf so laut sie drei vier
gegenspieler auf sich frei waren für
wünschen zugriff wo ein klasse-tor die
streich truppe streichelt den ball wie
barcelona
die eintracht findet lange kein mittel
gegen das freiburger abwehr bollwerk
filipovic in der 54 minute und der
östlichen beschreibung
dortmund hat einen historischen joker
freiburg einen jederzeit sogar nils
petersen acht minuten nach seiner
einwechslung mit dem siegtreffer vor dem
rückspiel in barcelona einen dämpfer für
die eintracht die natürlich auch in der
nächsten saison wieder in europa spielen
möchte er hätte gerne noch mehr buttons
von internationalen auswärtsfahrten auf
seinem bullen kopf leipzig will in die
champions league hoffenheim träumt
zumindest davon die führung für rb in
der fünften minute christopher in kongo
muss beim jubeln allerdings noch warten
der video assistent korrigiert kurze
zeit später die abseitsentscheidung von
schiedsrichter dank hat die
tsg agiert viel zu zurückhaltend laimer
einfach mal durch die mitte der ball
landet bei halstenberg und der hat das
mit dem linken fuß nicht verliert der
ex-nationalspieler war lange verletzt
und steht nach 323 tagen wieder in der
stadt alle treffer des spiels fallen in
der ersten halbzeit den kongo für
superschlau rb leipzig distanziert
hoffenheim in der tabelle auf sieben
zähler
der 29 spieltag in der übersicht
dortmund und bayern erfüllen ihre
pflichtaufgaben spektakuläre ergebnisse
in köln und berlin und nur in bochum gab
es eine nullnummer in der tabelle sind
die bayern unverändert mit 9 punkten vor
dortmund leipzig hat platz drei im
visier
rückschläge für hoffenheim und frankfurt
im kampf um die internationalen plätze
in der zweiten tabellenhälfte verbessern
sich gladbach und wolfsburg jeweils um
eine position stuttgart bielefeld hertha
der abstiegskampf bleibt spannend
[Applaus]
[Musik]